yeah as well i i did have this thought i
was like you know what it's like
i don't know if this is creepy or what
to some people but i think it's kind of
[ __ ] cool that like
my whole adult life is like captured in
like youtube
like you can see like my whole like
there'll be like 19. you can see
you can see the progress yeah you'll be
like 19 year old me that is like spots
and like [ __ ]
yeah you know pepperoni face and then
yeah in like 10 years you'll see me like
it's
it's the glow up yeah i think i think
it's kind of like i don't know i think
it's kind of fascinating that i can have
like a
you know as cringe as it might be i can
have like a backlog because
what i what i find interesting right is
you know we i don't know what it was
like for your parents but
my parents are like pretty old right now
so there's not too many photos
of when they were younger and like my
age especially
so you know i'd see photos here and then
you're just like damn that's what you
looks like
yeah like okay but for yeah you know
when we have kids
we have like our entire life just like
documented but that's that's true for
most people
like even above like being youtubers you
got facebook photos going back to like
my my kid will definitely know my entire
life up to like
um university yeah like there are some
uni photos where i'm just like
damn son or daughter i don't know if i
want you going through this man
yeah i don't know if it's good a bad
thing i pretty much purged like i lost a
lot of my photos pre-18 like on facebook
i pushed most of them
yeah because i hated how i looked in
them so yeah like [ __ ] it i mean no one
likes how they looked yeah yeah but i
thought should i keep them and i was
like no i'm getting rid of them so
actually i've lost a lot of them i
pretty much have like i would say an
average amount of like that anyone would
have
someone who took photos right yeah but i
think it's cool as an adult i could make
the choice to be like i'm fine with
having most of my like adult life
essentially be documented i think that's
kind of cool i mean whether my
future kids think so yeah he's like
that's up to them but i i'm i'm sorry
for any future kid who goes through my
twitter timeline god i'm so [ __ ]
sorry
i'm sure twitter at some point will do
like a big purge
of life do you think so because how can
you store all that [ __ ] no
i think they can because i mean that
just means like that youtube
you know all the youtube videos in the
world have a finite shelf life and
basically every media
and every big website in the world has a
finite shelf life right
yeah surely so i don't know i i like
like you said like
when it comes to online media i kind of
act like a hoarder right
like i don't know what i can look back
yeah exactly
i don't know what i could look back in a
few years and be like yeah
i tweeted that back in 2008 or
i couldn't remember when i started my
twitter man it's been it's been a while
i didn't even know twitter was that old
to be honest
yeah yeah because i have i have this
thing on i don't know if you have it i
think you do right
where like i have this thing on my
twitter where like if the tweet is older
than two months then it automatically
deletes it
right i think that mine's set like two
years just because like every time i
look back at myself two years i'm like
[ __ ] us cringy
yeah yeah but i'm like that six months
ago so i'm just like
i like the ability to look back and be
like man i was [ __ ] cringy
i like the ability to look back and go
man what the [ __ ] with this was this
anime zone hairstyle
what the [ __ ] man i got that on youtube
that's what the youtube channel is for
the twitch clips you know all that [ __ ]
that's what that's for yeah yeah yeah i
already have like one website to like
remind me of how cringy i used to be i
want like multiple websites to remind me
how cringy i used to be
i want to know what [ __ ] cringey
thoughts i had so you know that's that's
it's not just pictures i want everything
like i don't want to go back on like my
my personal facebook and then go back to
like you know 2010 and being like oh god
why the [ __ ] did i tweet [ __ ] out like
that or messing [ __ ] out